bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
une déclaration de candidature à la
présidentielle n'est jamais anodine et
on lui prête un impact symbolique très
fort Jacques Chirac a choisi la
spontanéité et la surprise aussi il
n'était que quelques-uns à être dans la
confidence c'était donc en milieu de
journée à Avignon regardez c s
commentaires comme si vous y étiez
Jacques Chirac répond à une question
elle est posée par la maire de la Ville
Marie José rag depuis quelques
jours je ne peux pas faire un pas hors
de chez moi ou de ma mairie sans qu'on
me pose la question et je crois que
cette question on se la pose partout en
France le président va-t-il déclarer sa
candidature alors cher Marie José
r Je vous l'ai dit vous m'avez posé une
question directe et franche bien j'y
répondrai dans le même
esprit oui je suis
[Applaudissements]
candidat et j'ai
voulu et j'ai voulu le dire au milieu
des Français je participerai donc au
grand débat qui est déjà
engagé un débat dont je souhaite qu'il
soit digne et qu'il soit serein c'est ce
qu'attend
compatriote je m'engage donc je crois en
la
France je connais et j'aime les
Français j'ai confiance dans leur
capacité et je suis sûr que tous
ensemble au-delà des idéologies au-delà
des préjugés au-delà des dogmes par le
dialogue et dans le respect de
chacun nous pouvons faire gagner la
France et c'est pour cela que je suis
candidat heureux de vous l'avoir dit et
je vous remercie de votre
accueil